[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast for me
and my brother John answer your
questions give you Dibby u s-- advice
and bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon how you
doing John I'm doing okay you may recall
from past podcast that I've been a
little anxious about getting norovirus a
disease that makes you vomit copiously I
got it I got it oh I had a I had a
puking puking disease last night I woke
up at 1:30 in the morning and I thought
something is terribly wrong and then I
vomited several times over the next
three hours and now I feel fine oh good
well I'm glad you feel fine it's funny
last year around Thanksgiving we we had
norovirus together I was just
remembering that it's an amazing thing
how sometimes these things just come
back seasonally but it was it was a
particularly mild attack of
gastroenteritis and I feel I honestly
kind of better than I did even a couple
days ago so I'm doing well how are you
I'm good I'm sitting in a very nice
hotel room in Seattle Washington looking
out at this Seattle cityscape of some
sort I'm right next to the Seattle Times
offices I'm here to interview Randall
Munroe
the creator of xkcd on stage about his
new book thing explainer I'm excited
about doing at the Town Hall here in
Seattle highly recommended by the way I
really really like xkcd and Randall
Monroe's work in general he is a very
he's very smart guy and he's the kind of
smart that I like a lot where there's a
lot of like technical science stuff but
then every once in a while he throws in
some really good analysis of how humans
behave because I think oftentimes we
forget how important human behavior is
and how unlike science it is yeah he's
also just great at explaining things to
people who aren't very bright like
myself uses so your overall you're in a
good mood I would say I'm in a good mood
yes great because I have a short poem
about death for you today awesome this
was recommended by Kimmy it's called the
virtue by George err bear her bear
Herbert will say Herbert
sweet day so cool so calm so bright the
bridal of the earth and sky
the dew shall weep thy fall tonight for
thou must die sweet rose whose hue angry
and brave bids the rash gazer wipe his
eye
thy roof tis ever in its grave and now
must die sweet spring full of sweet days
and roses a box were sweets compacted by
my music shows he have your closes and
all must die only a sweet and virtuous
soul like seasoned timber never gives
but though the whole world turned to
coal then chiefly lives virtue by George
hair bear herb heir Herbert I'm so good
at last names it was a poem from the
seventeenth-century Hank I feel like we
don't have enough 17th century poems
about death on this podcast oh that was
poem was also about life and it was also
not short I thought it was pretty short
but anyway I'm trying to keep my
consecutive streak of number of podcasts
that I've talked more than you alive I
see I see yeah I I do i I am looking
forward to hearing the analysis of last
week's podcast I I have not yet heard
who talked more after my attempts to be
more verbose do you want to do some
questions from the people John I feel
like we should answer questions from our
listeners most of which were submitted
at Hank and John at gmail.com if you
want to send us a question that's the
place to do it Hank how about we begin
with this question from Victor dear John
and Hank I recently became a dad there
are a lot of things I'm looking forward
to but the thing I'm looking forward to
the most
our dad jokes do you have any good ones
PS I am Hungarian and I would appreciate
some that are not puns and can be
translated I feel like dad jokes are
almost exclusively puns yeah that's what
I was gonna say as well I think that
you've got to talk to your Hungarian
friends about dad jokes because I can't
offer you any because all of mine are
extremely English dependent yeah uh-huh
yeah it's more a state of mind though a
dad joke you know tell dad jokes it has
to be something that you you realize you
know you know I have a theory about dad
jokes John my theory about dad jokes is
that when a kid is like three to five
dad jokes are actually the funniest
thing in the world the problem is that
the kid gets older and that the dad
doesn't evolve along with them and
continues to tell jokes for 3 to 5 year
olds for the dad's entire rest of the
dad's life that's very possible it would
also explain why I am to my children the
funniest person on earth right and you
what you just but you always want to go
back to that that like reach back to
that moment where you were like chief
funny person on earth and so you you
live that glory day by just telling dad
jokes for the rest of your life even
though no one enjoys them anymore
but you do because if you remember those
wonderful moments when your children
were children yeah and when they loved
you
completely and without any ambiguity I
think you're absolutely right Hank
although I don't recall our dad being a
particularly no dad joke kind of guy no
not really
he never never was but I am a god god I
love a good dad joke by the way Alice
made her first joke Hank oh yeah tell me
last night we were coming home from
McDonald's and yet did you ever it was
in our defense it was very late they
they had refused to eat at the place
where we went out to with friends so we
had to get them something I apologized
to all the food he's out there but
anyway we were we were leaving
McDonald's and you have you ever had
like a one single onion ring in your
burger king fries yeah mm-hmm and you
know how exciting that is so Alice was
eating her french fries from her happy
meal and she said oh I got chicken
nugget in my flies and she was just so
excited and happy about it that
everybody laughed and she liked when
everybody laughed so then she paused for
a long time and she said I got a french
fry in my diaper that's great that's a
great joke and Henry I mean Henry was
just like oh man she has figured it out
she's figured out the number one joke
construction something involving poop
yep and then that's it really that's it
that's the only thing yeah okay we have
another question John this is from Jesse
who asks I have a big family and I'm a
college student with no income and
barely a hundred dollars to my name we
all agreed earlier this year that we
would get everybody something for
Christmas but trying to find gifts that
won't completely destroy my bank account
is seriously stressing me out what would
you recommend I get for my siblings and
parents for Christmas Jesse I suggest
you get for them your future financial
security mm-hmm and get them nothing
yeah or get them something that you make
by hand
yes you know the thing out of free
supplies that do not cost it right like
this so poop and your diaper put a
french fry in your diaper everyone's
gonna love it
the gift that I gave my mom that meant
that most to her was a shoebox full of
reasons I loved her that I just like cut
up you know into like from a piece of
paper I just wrote him out and then cut
him cut him up and she could just sort
of like pick one out whenever I was
infuriating her and be reminded of the
fact that I was by far the best son yes
that is and that cost note that is a
that is a very good gift probably better
than anything I ever gave our mom I yeah
so things you make if you if you are I
don't know like it it's a little bit you
know different people are motivated by
different things and some people really
like to receive a gift that had some
kind of thought into it and was also
purchased now like the value on putting
value on something that was acquired is
troubling and like hopefully your family
doesn't do that too much but I I would
also say that one of my favorite cheap
gifts if you are definitely going to
spend some money is to go to a used book
store and buy some used books yeah
because they they they are inexpensive
and wonderful yeah I mean all obviously
all used books are inexpensive and
wonderful but let me particularly
recommend my used books maybe used John
Green books
yeah maybe a dog-eared old copy of The
Fault in Our Stars from that first
signed edition or let it snow the the
holiday romance book I wrote with
Maureen Johnson and Lauren Myracle but
other books are good too the great thing
about a used book store is that you can
go in with 20 bucks and if you're pretty
smart
you can walk out with all of seven gifts
that you need for all of the people in
your family and then not only have you
had a relatively inexpensive Christmas
you've also had a relatively quick one
yeah it's true it's true that is it is
definitely time consuming especially
for a student who is full-time learning
stuff doesn't want to be spending too
much time on the gift acquisition I
there's actually a used bookstore in
Missoula and I don't know if other
people places have something like this
where you can take your books and they
will give you credit and then you can
get the other books for free basically
and I have like one hundred and fifty
dollars in credit at that store right
now so I basically I can go in there and
as long as I'm buying a used paperback
it's free Hank this question comes from
Taylor and it's tailor-made for me Hank
Dear John and Hank
I was recently in chemistry class and
started to wonder did we actually
discover the periodic table or did we
invent it are all discoveries and nature
inventions to allow people to better
understand the universe or are the
distinctions and methods of organization
already in existence when we find them
that is a great question for me Taylor
it is right in my wheelhouse and here is
how I shall answer it Hank I'm gonna
answer this question it's going to be
maybe a little bit esoteric because I
was once an actual chemist so the
periodic table is is an invention in
that it is a way of expressing something
that we discovered so it is an invented
way of expressing a discovery and that
discovery is that there are repeating
characteristics of elements so there's
as long before we understood that atoms
even were and what atoms were made of
anything about protons and neutrons and
electrons what we meaning Dmitri
Mendeleev noticed that certain elements
behaved similarly and that they were
separated from each other by repeating
numbers of non similar elements so like
there would be like in terms of like the
the increasing mass of those elements
and that was a discovery it was a
discovery about the nature of the
universe something that actually has
always been that we did not know and
then we knew and then we had to explain
that discovery and part of the
explanation of that discovery was like
creating the entire idea of what an atom
is how they behave what electrons are
and and that discovery allowed us
insight into those things which was was
wonderful so we were finding something
out about the nature of the universe it
was a discovery but the way that it is
displayed in classrooms
that is just a tool that we invented to
help us understand that discovery and to
display that discovery and there are
many alternate ways of displaying the
periodic table of elements or the
periodicity of elements that are not the
periodic tables you can find those by
like go Google alternate periodic tables
and you can see a bunch of really cool
ways that other people have have come up
with for displaying that periodicity do
you want to know more than that John no
although I do feel that I have learned
something from today's podcast which is
a kind of rare so thanks but give me a
chemistry question I'll be happy to
oblige I'm always amazed by the fact
that you actually know a lot of
chemistry because you're so talented at
pretending to know something when you
sort of like one third know it you know
and so like when we come across a
subject that you're actually pretty
familiar with I'm always impressed by
the way I mean the only person I know
who's better at acting like they know a
lot about something when they only when
they only are 33% well educated about it
is me so I'm not trying to insult you at
all it is a green family trait this is
how I've learned I learned from the best
this new question however is is one that
I think might be very tense for us
because we are both experts in this
field it comes from Maya and she writes
dear John and Hank I have had a pressing
question on my mind for a few years now
what time is it okay to start listening
to holiday music the day after
Thanksgiving oh we aren't gonna disagree
because I could not agree with you more
in fact I think that if you start
listening to holiday music the day
before Thanksgiving you are essentially
a sociopathic monster and if you start
listening to things and if you start
listening to holiday music even a week
after Thanksgiving you are equally
terrible the day to start listening to
holiday music is the day after
Thanksgiving because that's when you're
supposed to get in the consumeristic
moon right that tells yourself I should
go to dftba.com and get a pizza John
shirt yeah
it is important that we continue to
sustain the American economy and the
only way in which we do that is
fourth-quarter sales based on this this
peculiar consumerist gift-giving
tradition that we have I now back to the
original question I think that it is
okay to listen to Christmas music
anytime after Thanksgiving it up to
Christmas I don't think that there is a
time I think that it's not ok to listen
to Christmas Eve before Thanksgiving
because I think it subtracts from
Thanksgiving which is actually my
favorite holiday and I don't want people
to mess with Thanksgiving by like having
Christmas over take it so when I
whenever I hear Christmas song on the
radio before Thanksgiving I scream in
anger and I do not listen to that radio
station ever again
because I because I feel that they are
taking away Thanksgiving which is the
best American holiday and I will not
stand for it
his Thanksgiving really your favorite
holiday yes I love Thanksgiving it is so
good he's supposed to ask me what my
favorite holiday is what is your
favorite holiday job Labor Day going
away I love Labor Day uh I got it I got
another question John this question is
from Alex who's asks dear Hank and John
last year my friends and I made a video
game which we released in July we have
had some very unexpected commercial
success to the point where we are now
able to be self-employed do you have any
dubious advice for running a business in
creating a place where people want to
work
I'm finding it especially hard as my
colleagues are my friends how do you
make difficult grown-up business
decisions when you're old friends
interesting well first off Alex let me
just say that you need to work on your
marketing because you had an amazing
opportunity and strong your question to
tell us the name of your video game that
I would have immediately bought but you
didn't um so now I'm just sitting here
wondering is it fallout4 or is it
something else I mean I think this is
really difficult I think it's a really
hard thing to go from you know people
making stuff for fun together to a
business
and I would encourage you that too
insofar as possible not to make that
transition unless you really really want
to you know Hank and I have both very
consciously chosen not to grow as fast
as some of our companies might have
grown because we don't want to like you
know be running gigantic businesses and
because we want to work with people who
are really good to work with as far as
like motivating employees who are also
your friends
good luck that sounds hard I mean I
think it's really I think there are
obvious benefits to working with your
friends but you know it can anytime
money gets introduced into those
conversations it can become very awkward
and difficult and I just try to be as as
transparent as possible and as open and
honest as possible and and hope that
like we can all keep working together on
something not for money ultimately but
because we love it and and and kind of
keep that feeling that we had when we
were at the beginning of it you know
there's that white stripe song when
you're in your little room and you're
working on something good but if you but
if it's really good you might need a
bigger room and then you're gonna have
to think about how it felt being in that
little room so like as things die I just
absolutely butcher to white stripes on I
butchered it so bad that I don't think
Jack white can sue us for copyright
infringement in your life you will be in
a bigger room than you expected to be in
and you will not know how to feel but
the way to feel is the way that you felt
back when you were in your garage or in
your basement or wherever you were when
you were making the thing indeed that is
a good song that is that is a full of
surprising business advice yeah I it's
also only 40 seconds but also so yeah I
would also look at other people and ask
the people who have had similar things
happen to them my and so cards against
humanity' is a really interesting
example because they have become just
like there's been a massive amount of
success at cards against humanity' and
they they have kept it really
interesting and really in and like they
continue to not really have a lead
among their friend group so it's just
some friends who came up with this idea
and then they did it and and there's
sort of like a leadership structure but
nobody's in charge there
they just do and and know they're like
they'll just share everything equally
and they you know so there's two ways
you can do it you could just sort of say
like we're just gonna be friends and
we're gonna do a weird thing and try not
to care too much or you've got to set up
some kind of management structure where
one person is in charge it is very
difficult to run a business we're not
where there is not just one person in
charge and unless you all agree that
this is just about having a good time
because if it becomes about how do you
make money that becomes a very wittily
question and it's never quite clear how
the best way to make money is especially
when there can be lots of other
variables in that equation that have to
do with like how do you also like enjoy
the thing you're doing and to be a good
person at the same time yeah I mean it's
an incredible privilege to be in a
situation where you can love what you do
but you cannot lose sight of the
importance of your values and you know
what what matters to you I mean you've
got to kind of pick your priorities you
know are the priority is gonna be
friendships and relationships or are the
priorities gonna be trying to get as big
as you can and trying to take over the
world for me it's destroying all of my
relationships if I can just take over
the world and I resist I will not let
you destroy this relationship no matter
how much evil you do to me brother
that's so ludicrous I don't know which
of us is which of us is the bigger pull
against growing but I think it's me ya
know I think it's you - I think it's you
okay this is a question from Wade and it
is very important he writes Dear John
and Hank I need your dubious advice I
want to crash the moon into the earth I
know from my physics classes that the
waves in the ocean are the result of
moon's gravitational forces so is it
possible to put turbines in the ocean
which would disrupt these waves in such
a way that they would provide a
gravitational gravitational force on the
moon slowing it down and eventually
deorbiting it and
resulting in the moon crashing into the
earth Wade I'll tell you what I like
about your question I love a person of
ambition and you are seriously ambitious
I mean you just lay it out there right
there in the second sentence of your
question I want to crash the moon into
the earth but why would we give you
advice why would we say wait you know
what we're going to help to destroy me
because we have competing interests so
the answer to your question is that if
you want to crash the moon into the
earth the number one way to do that is
to go right now to patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John and become a
supporter of this very podcast it works
every time every time someone supports
dear Hank and John on patreon the moon
gets one centimeter closer to earth
that's science so all you have to do is
get people to sign up and I haven't
having a really hard time actually not
answering this question because I kind
of find it a little bit fascinating but
I'm not gonna do it good I'm glad
because I'm a seriously wait wait might
crash the moon into the earth which from
what I understand would be tremendously
destructive to both the moon and the
earth you know yeah I would kill it
would kill everything oh you're so
casual about it Hank we've worked so
hard for so many billions of years to
reach the point where life can
extinguish itself and and we've finally
done it congratulations
today's podcast is brought to you by
life the most interesting thing the
universe has ever done but make no
mistake about it temporary today's
podcast is brought to you by your needy
family there's seven of them and they
all want gifts today's podcast is also
brought to you by Victor who recently
became a dad Victor he's gonna find out
that dad jokes just come out here
naturally this is today this podcast is
also finally brought to you by all I
want for Christmas is you buy Mariah
Carey Oh
you buy Mariah Carey only available on
American radio stations after
Thanksgiving oh if you really want to
support our podcast you can do so at our
patreon as earlier mentioned we have a
patreon where you can support dear Hank
and John directly and help out
Nick Nick the producer in his producing
of these podcasts thank you thanks to
all of our patrons thank you
yes we just want to say if you if you
like dear Hank and John and you think
that it is a thing that you would pay
for then do it if you and if you don't
then don't it's really it's fine if you
can't okay we got a question from Didier
who writes Dear John and Hank I have the
choice between a job that I hate in a
city that I love or a job that I love in
a city that I hate what should I do
I don't even know I have no idea I don't
have enough data
John you go I mean I also don't have
enough data I need to know more about
the job and why did EI hates the city
that the lovely job is in but my ink so
I have gone back and forth on this
question over the years I remember
believing when I was 23 believing very
strongly in fact I wrote it above my
computer where I wrote at night that
what you do does not matter as much as
who you do it with and I still mostly
believe that I think and who you do it
with is also a function of where you do
it this this whole thing sounds dirtier
than it is right because like for
instance you know my one of my oldest
and closest friends Shannon James lives
in Chicago and for many many years we
lived together and and those years were
incredibly important to me creatively
and personally and they couldn't have
happened outside of Chicago in fact a
lot of the work that I did when I lived
in Chicago couldn't have happened
outside of Chicago and now I live in a
place where you know
it isn't like I feel like Indianapolis
doesn't have a specific a place identity
as Chicago or New York did the places we
lived before but at the same time I love
it here and I wouldn't want to live
anywhere else so I moved here we moved
here because Sarah had a job she loved
and we fully thought that we were going
to a place that we were going to hate
but that it was like necessary for
Sarah's career to move forward and now
it turns out that we really love
Indianapolis so I just I would be a
little suspicious of deciding that you
hate a place in advance unless you know
it very well and you still hate it in
which case I don't know I'm not
answering the question yeah I would also
say that I would be suspicious of
knowing you're gonna hate or love a job
before you do it unless you have done it
before I or worked for that company
before I I think that we are as humans
are bad at knowing what we will enjoy
that's so true
it's so it's so hard to know in advance
what's going to be good like that's the
thing that astonishes me about marriage
that so many marriages succeed in the
sense that one person dies before the
marriage is dissolved by a divorce I
guess I guess it's not really a success
but that's that's what passes for
success when it comes to marriage but it
astonishes me that so many marriages
don't end in divorce because I don't
know if you feel this way Hank but like
I'm very happily married but when I made
all of those promises that I made on my
wedding day I had no idea what I was
getting into indeed in fact let's have
this be a question from Caitlin who asks
dear Hank and John I've heard a lot both
on this podcast and elsewhere that
marriage is a lot of work can you
explain more about what that means how
does the amount of work already involved
in keeping a serious long-term
cohabitating relationship healthy change
once there are rings in the picture how
do I know if my partner and I are ready
to take this step Thanks and I love the
podcast I look forward to it every week
oh thanks Caitlin yeah I mean I don't
know that it changes because of the
rings exactly I think that a long-term
cohabitating relationship over decades
probably also takes
work yes yeah I think that I I don't
think that the Rings changes it I think
that the commitment changes it in the
and that the knowing that that you are
going to be different people in
different places and doing different
things over the decades that will come
and and yet you will and yet you will
have this thing be the thing that
continues to to be a steady thing in
your life even though you have both
changed and are now not the same people
that you once were that is that is
inevitable and fine and and something to
expect and and but but keeping that
commitment strong and keeping that the
love between you strong and you know
there is is it is one of the great
projects of a person's life is
maintaining these relationships and
having them remain fulfilling and
rewarding yeah I think a lot of what
people mean when they talk about
marriage or other long-term lifelong
relationships being work is that they
require attention and it's easy not to
give them attention you know like it's
easy it's easy to sort of feel like okay
where the co-ceos of this family and as
such
soccer practice has to start now and
this check has to be written now and you
will do this and I will do that and you
lose track of the fact that you have
this relationship that you have to
nurture and pay sustained attention to
and so I think that's a lot of what
people mean when they say that it's work
just that it requires effort and it
requires attention I agree with you John
the only other thing I would say to you
Caitlyn just in an attempt to make sure
that I talked more than Hank in this
podcast is that like your circumstances
in life are definitely going to change
right like your your life is going to be
different in ways that you by definition
cannot possibly imagine so the
commitment is more to saying you are the
person that I think so far as I can tell
I want to be on that journey with even
though all kinds of things could happen
that would dramatically change both of
us I'm
you know I want to try to do this with
you and I think that's the that's the
decision really the decision is you know
that that two lives do in a sense become
one is that fair Hank that's fair I
think that was very well said and and
full of words which is the important
thing for your records
this this question is from Brandon who
asks dear Hank and John Oxford
dictionary's Word of the Year for 2015
is actually a pictograph it's an emoji
for those who don't know what a
pictograph is and this has created some
mixed feelings inside of me on the one
hand it's silly on the face of it
because it's really a word in the sense
of the word word as it is not
pronounceable and arguably isn't
writable but on the other hand it does
appear to be a meaningful way that
people communicate in 2015 for better
and for worse and I don't want to be a
prescriptive as grandpa yelling at kids
to get their newfangled linguistics off
my proverbial lon
are these both valid reactions and if so
how can i reconcile them into a nuanced
and fair point of view on the word in
quotation marks of the year I think you
just did it Brandon I think you just I
think you just had you just showed me
your nuanced and fair point of view you
just did it happened you're done what do
you think John yeah I mean I I recently
read an emoji version of my novel The
Fault in Our Stars and I found it to be
astonishingly encyclopedic I read the
emoji version of The Fault in Our Stars
and I thought to myself that pretty much
covers it yeah so it's true that emojis
aren't word aren't words in the
traditional sense of words but Brandon
as you point out it's an important part
for better and for worse of how people
talk to each other these days so I
thought it was a cool choice for word of
the year and I I think that you are at a
fair and nuanced point point of view so
congratulations yeah I mean I think that
it's important to I think it's cool that
Oxford did this that Oxford dictionary's
did this because like what did you know
like they have words like they
they are you know it's nice for them to
say like words are bigger than words and
and symbols and you know like the ways
that people connect with each other are
you know are bigger than just the the
noises that come out of our mouths and
especially in a world in which a lot of
text communication happens and we have
found new and more efficient ways to
communicate things that aren't you know
strings of letters and what what an
interesting thing to be happening and
what a smart thing for Oxford
dictionary's to recognize that hey
before we get to the news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon I just have to say one
thing which is that the project for
awesome our annual charity event is
occurring this year on December 11th and
12th please be part of it with us please
check out project for awesome calm there
are amazing perks that you can get for
donating to organizations like Save the
Children and the UN's High Commission on
refugees I can't reveal any of those
perks now because I don't want to spoil
it but they are great so please check
out project for awesome calm on the 11th
and 12th of December and also join us
for the live stream which is always a
good time Hank and I livestream along
with other people in the nerdfighter
community for 48 hours straight and it's
gonna be a blast indeed and if you are
interested in making a project for
awesome video you can do that and the
way to do that is to make any video that
is promoting a charity of your choice
letting people know about the cool work
that is being done by people who work
hard to make the world suck less world I
just had to say the word weird world
again because apparently I have a
problem yeah who's gonna say do you just
have to say world at the end of every
sentence world world and if people vote
for your charity at
projectforawesome.com that charity can
receive lots and lots of money
like like tens of thousands of dollars
so it's definitely worth making a
project for awesome video sharing it
with your friends and generally
spreading the word about the project for
awesome world alright what is the news
from Mars
oh well NASA is working on new Mars
ready spacesuits
because they got to get ready for being
on Mars in the 2030s which is the
current plan and that means developing
new spacesuits that will work better on
Mars than than the ones we have that
mostly function for space just as
floating around outside of space
stations so more mobile and but still
pressurized and but allowing the the ash
bounce of the future to walk around on
the surface of Mars and do the important
work of Mars Inc
and learning on Mars and discovering on
Mars it's called the z2 it is a it is a
very cool fancy spacesuit it's it's a
we've you've been used to seeing sort of
like the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man kind
of looking thing with the white they're
all white this is sort of a gray and
black and it's got cool logos on it and
it looks freaking awesome super excited
about it and they're going to be using
3d scans of astronauts bodies to make
sure that the they they fit perfectly
but they can also be used
interchangeably in case something goes
wrong and I like it a lot so it's the z2
and you can check it out by googling
that and you see what you can see what
future astronauts will be wearing on the
surface of Mars fingers crossed so
there's like logos on the spacesuits
themselves are they like AFC Wimbledon
logos that are on the uniforms like does
it is it corporate stuff or is it just
does it say like NASA just the massive
stuff there's an F there's something
there's something weird on the chest
which I don't know if it's a logo or
it's just sort of a design does not look
familiar it looks like a logo but it
doesn't look familiar to me as far as
what the logo is is there any way do you
think that dear Hank and John could
potentially sponsor the Mars suits the
way that we sponsor AFC Wimbledon I
don't know if everybody works at NASA
and wants to you know and talked to us
about a sponsorship we've got you know
thousands of dollars potentially maybe
hundreds that we could probably hundreds
we could get involved in this in this
project I know that you need everything
all the help you can get to get people
onto Mars I can't imagine that
sponsoring Mars spacesuits would be more
expensive
than sponsoring AFC Wimbledon shorts
because AFC Wimbledon is so much more
important and also there are so many
more of them there's only gonna be like
nine astronauts at Mars there's 23
members of AFC Wimbledon III yep all
right so you know that it's been a
period of darkness I've heard well I
mean AFC Wimbledon continued to be a
very strange team this year we lost to
dag and red down there in 22nd place
basically a likely relegation team a
team that could end up out of the
Football League entirely and they
semi-professional football conference
that's the fifth tier of English soccer
but then this weekend we went ahead and
we had a very very good draw with Leyton
Orient I was a 1-1 tie the goal was
scored by the beast out of viola Confed
wah
my favorite AFC Wimbledon player seems
to do most of most of the scoring he
does a lot of the scoring but you
remember that Lyle Taylor the montserrat
Ian international has also done a fair
bit of scoring this season yes
also Lyle Taylor yes while Taylor
inaudible walk and fen well along with
AH daisies have done almost all of the
scoring but anyway it was a and the
commentators at least said that it was
very possible that we could have won the
game and they are Leyton Orient are
above us on the table and a very likely
team to move up to Ligue 1 next year so
you know it just goes to show you
there's a lot of parity and league to a
lot of weird stuff can happen but after
20 games it's 46 game season Hank after
20 games that reduces to 10 13 where
nope nope nope no it doesn't 1016 what
how many Hank what is 2046 that's 10 20
thirds aftert we're 10 20 thirds of the
way through the league to season and so
1020 thirds of the way into the season
um AFC Wimbledon our 11th out of the 24
teams in league 2 sitting on 28 points
we are only 3 points out of eighth but
to get into the playoff spots which is 3
4 5 & 6
we're currently five points away from
the playoffs so we're doing better than
we were this time last season but still
not quite as good as I would like I'm
sorry but also hopeful for the future of
this sports team this week I didn't
manage to get you to care about either
fourth tier soccer or poetry I'll have
to give it a go next time but I got you
to care about chemistry kinda you did
you did but then I got completely bored
during this stuff about the Mars space
suit like we already have spacing so
we're gonna have a slightly better one I
don't know it started to get really
excited about that all right John what
did we learn today well we learned that
dad jokes aren't something you tell so
much as there's something that you are
we learned also that there's a man named
Wade and we should be very careful about
giving Wade information about how to
crash the moon into the earth because he
seems to be very ambitious
we also learned some chemistry which was
refreshing oh yeah I'm very glad to have
have learned some chemistry with you we
learned that that having a nuanced point
and fair point of view on the use of
emojis as words of the year is not as
hard as some people think it is and of
course we learned that the day after
Thanksgiving and not one minute before
is the time to start listening to
holiday music all right John
thanks for doing a podcast with me thank
you before thank you to everyone for
listening as well if you want to write
us questions you can do so at Hank and
John at gmail.com or use the hashtag
dear Hank and John on Twitter on the
Twitter's I am John Green Hank is Hank
green on snapchat Hanks preferred method
of communication he is Hank GRE and I am
John Green snaps John Green's naps Solms
checked this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins the theme music is from
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown
don't forget to be awesome
[Music]